a new united nations report on climate
change says the world needs to move away
from fossil fuels and quickly to have
any hope of preventing a climate
disaster in the future now there is some
good news the world's leading climate
scientists say we still have time to
avert a catastrophe if we act now ben
tracy has more
it's now or never scientists say to
avoid the worst impacts of climate
change the new un report says greenhouse
gas emissions must be cut nearly in half
by 2030 to have any chance of limiting
global warming to 2.7 degrees fahrenheit
any warmer than that and floods droughts
fires and other climate catastrophes
become much worse we are on a fast track
to climate disaster the u.n secretary
general says many governments and
businesses are not doing nearly enough
to cut their pollution simply put they
are lying
and the results will be catastrophic
this is a climate emergency the report
says the world must essentially stop
burning coal dramatically reduce the use
of oil and gas and quickly transition to
cleaner forms of energy such as wind
solar and nuclear power
and accelerate the transition to
electric vehicles there is optimism
because the cost of ev batteries and
renewable energy have dropped
dramatically but given the overall lack
of climate action scientists say we may
also need costly technology like this
facility we visited last year in iceland
that sucks planet-warming carbon dioxide
emissions out of the air
for cbs mornings i'm ben tracy